Ви не маєте вагатися, ви маєте це зробити.
Це дійсно найважчі години в житті. Це як у спорті.
Якщо ти не продовжуєш піднімати планку, то не стаєш чемпіоном.
Нарешті! Відчуття - нарешті це розпочинається.
Бо я знала про це вже дуже давно, ще з 2018-го. І якщо весь час цього очікуєш
і готуєшся, готуєшся, готуєшся, колись воно вже має статися.
Я відчуваю, так би мовити, велику енергію, яка акумулювалася за це час.
Це справді абсолютно чудово - концентруватися лише на творі та музиці.
Байройт, червень 2021-го. Ми зустрічаємося із Оксаною Линів
за п’ять тижнів до великої прем’єри на зеленому пагорбі.
Чому цій молодій жінці, з невеликого українського містечка, вдається те,
чого ще ніколи не робила жодна жінка:
бути першою жінкою, яка диригує в Байройті.
Оксана Линів поза сценою любить кубинську музику.
Вона - жінка з великим темпераментом. Її кар’єра набирає обертів.
Ідеальний початок - у 2013 році в Баварській державній опері.
Як асистентка вона вже сама стоїть біля пульту - і надихає.
Потім головна диригентка в австрійському Граці.
Після цього - Мюнхенська філармонія, Державна капела у Берліні.
З 2020-го дебюти у Відні, Парижі та Болоньї.
А восени 2021 року - Берлінська філармонія!
Такого не вдавалося ще жодній диригентці.
Але тепер - новий виклик: Байройт - кульмінація дотеперішньої кар'єри.
Позаду тебе ця фестивальна зала. Це символічне місце. Ваґнер, так би мовити,
у тебе на шиї. Це для тебе тягар чи втіха?
Музика Ваґнера - це, гадаю, доволі сильний наркотик.
Якщо ти це раз спробував, то тобі цього вже бракує.
Я навіть якось написала у Фейсбуку, що коли диригуєш Вагнера,
то в тебе відчуття, що ти маєш палаюче повітря під руками.
Інтерес до неї - у соціальних мережах - величезний. Адже це
дещо незвично: жінка за диригентським пультом у Байройті.
Початок був особливо складним. Для кожної жінки
особливо важко пробитися на початку. Але тепер уже інакше.
Мені це також важливо ще й тому, бо це має бути приклад, сподіваюся, позитивний
для майбутнього. Але від того, що я жінка, чи навіть якби я була чоловіком,
партитура "Голландця" не буде легшою чи важчою.
"Летючий голландець" Оксані Линів знайомий, вона диригує його не вперше.
Вагнер пише "романтичну оперу" глибоко пригнічений як невизнаний
молодий композитор, під враженням бурхливого плавання,
і тут простежуються такі теми як туга, смерть та спокута.
Тоді він сказав, я пишу музику для першої німецької опери "Летючого голландця".
І це обурення, ця сила справді відчувається вже у перших акордах увертюри,
де він справді всі можливі засоби задіяв.
І цей океан з цими хвилями - це було якраз те, що він відчував.
Сюди, до Одеси на Чорноморське узбережжя, Оксана Линів любить приїздити.
Тут вона може відпочити та зосередитися на своїй роботі.
Тут почався її підйом як маестро.
В оперному театрі спостерігаємо за нею під час репетиції "Євгенія Онєгіна" Чайковського.
Оксана - сконцентрована, люб'язна, але водночас
зосереджена та вимоглива.
Давайте, як биття серця.
Вона добре знає, чого хоче, й отримує це.
Не разом! Ви просто не разом! Ми не можемо цього лишити,
бо ми не разом. І - раз!
Оксана дуже харизматична, пристрасна як диригентка.
Я шокована, як багато в неї енергії.
І це завжди дуже надихає.
Не буває лячно, тому що знову ж таки всі її вимоги як диригентки
цілком виправдані. Вона вимоглива в ім'я музики,
в ім'я мистецтва. Тому тут жодного страху чи боязні не може бути.
Я не хочу справляти враження надміру суворої.
Йдеться радше про те, що це справді керівна позиція. Це означає,
я кажу, що я хочу, але я також несу відповідальність за те, щоб це функціонувало.
Іти вперед, не відпускати, довіряти собі - таке ментальне налаштування
на шляху до Байройта. А також наставник Кирило Петренко.
Нині він - керівник Берлінської філармонії, а до цього
головний диригент Баварської державної опери.
Від Кирила Петренка я найбільше навчилася.
Хоча про саме диригентство ми майже не говорили,
я ніколи не чула від нього якихось вказівок. Гадаю, наша співпраця тому
так добре спрацювала, бо я розумію його стиль, як він хоче чути оркестр.
Оксана Линів - перша жінка-диригент в Одесі.
Вона перша і в Байройті. Чи має жінка-диригент бути вимогливішою за чоловіка-диригента?
Мені важливо, щоб усе пройшло, як я собі уявляю.
І якщо щось іде не так або це неможливо, тоді це мають бути дуже поважні причини.
Тоді я мушу знаходити нові компроміси.
Їй, звісно, нелегко…
У другій половині дня
Оксана Линів показує мені одне з найулюбленіших місць:
тут, на пляжі в Одесі, вона в дитинстві часто бувала з батьками та братом.
Коли ти в морі купаєшся, ти відчуваєш себе частиною дихання всесвіту.
Мені подобається, коли на морі сильні хвилі. Хвилі і вітер - це як початок
"Летючого голландця". Зі свистом вітру
і сильними небезпечними для життя хвилями.
Вагнер ніколи не відпускає її.
Його партитури супроводжують Оксану Линів у всіх її подорожах…
Ваґнер зі своїми ідеями, зі своєю неймовірно титанічною енергією,
зі своєю реформою опери,
яка справді усю передісторію опери на абсолютно нові рейки перевела.
Її захоплюють й історичні мотиви, також і в політиці.
За декілька днів до цього - на Майдані у Києві. Оксана Линів - не лише диригентка,
а й патріотка з чіткими політичними переконаннями - також і щодо
збройного конфлікту з Росією.
Це доленосне місце для українців.
Наприкінці 2013-го сотні тисяч людей відстояли тут мирний курс на Європу.
Проросійський президент Віктор Янукович перед цим виступив проти зближення з ЄС.
Тоді, у лютому 2014 року, сталася трагедія:
близько 100 людей загинули, коли силовики
стріляли бойовими патронами у демонстрантів.
Оксана Линів була в той час у Мюнхені.
Цей день я дуже добре пам'ятаю. Мене запросили
асистенткою музичного директора Кирила Петренка, і паралельно
я бачила в інтернеті всі ці страшні картини, коли студенти, жертви лежали просто тут
у церкві і були накриті білими простирадлами. Важко було взагалі в це повірити,
що в наш мирний час посеред Європи щось подібне взагалі є можливим.
Тут, на Майдані, Оксана Линів замислена: стільки жертв…
і нескінченний конфлікт, що розділяє Україну.
Вона не залишається осторонь, а намагається теж бути активною.
Я можу моїєю активною діяльністю у культурних проєктах цьому сприяти.
Приміром, заснування молодіжного оркестру - це була моя ідея 2017 року.
Молодь з цілої України - Сходу і Заходу - поєднати в одному музичному тілі
і тим самим практично заснувати нову сім'ю об'єднаної України.
Майже за пів тисячі кілометрів на захід від Києва знаходиться Львів,
мабуть, найбільш європейське місто в Україні.
Там навчалася Оксана Линів.
Збройний конфлікт України з Росією також відгукується жертвами і у Львові.
Оксана Линів хоче, щоб ми в гарнізонному храмі зустрілися з Тарасом Михальчуком.
Військовий капелан піклується про пам'ять полеглих.
Тут можна справді відчути і на власні очі побачити, що таке війна.
Усі предмети, ми бачимо тут, ці уламки зброї - усе це з лінії фронту.
Далі тут можна побачити галерею портретів дітей,
які витралили своїх батьків на війні.
Тут, приміром, написано: Марія, 3 роки: Мій тато на небі, мій любий тато, де ти?
Я хочу до тебе на руки, я хочу до тебе…
Коли почалася війна 2014-го, діти однієї з початкових шкіл цього міста
зробили цих білих голубів з паперу.
І ці голуби будуть тут висіти, поки не закінчиться війна.
Хоча вони вже постаріли і припали пилом,
але вони тут залишатимуться, поки не повернеться мир.
Як столиця Галичини Львів мав найтісніші зв'язки
із Західною Європою, з Австро-угорською імперією.
Оксана Линів приїхала сюди з містечка Броди у 1992 році,
щоб навчатися музиці - тут вона і починає диригувати.
Львів - це також фактично центр класичної музики, не Відень?
Неофіційно кажуть, що Львів - це культурна столиця України.
Власне, не Київ, а Львів завдяки традиції.
У Львові Оксана Линів пережила гірку невдачу. Коли була студенткою,
вона вивчила неправильну техніку, і їй довелося починати
все спочатку посеред навчання. Шок.
Наступного дня ми зустрічаємось у музичному училищі Оксани Линів.
Доброго дня!
Усі прийшли привітати видатну гостю. Тут пишаються такою знаменитою
ученицею. І їй теж приємно повернутися туди, де розпочалася її кар’єра.
Тут є також зала, в якій Оксана Линів вперше вийшла на сцену…
Спочатку із сопілкою та народною українською музикою.
Приватний урок для початківців…
І вступ до диригування…
Власне, ліва рука більш відповідальна за фразування
і за звучання, за вступи в опері.
Також дуже важливо, щоби права рука могла вести оркестр,
а лівою співакам сигналізувати про вступи.
Але права рука робить так: цак-цак-цак…
Що робить її особливою диригенткою?
Мабуть, це її сильна музична уява та незламна рішучість реалізувати свої ідеї з оркестром.
Як і тут, у "Каддіші", композиція Леонарда Бернстайна про єврейську молитву.
Оксана Линів диригує на Міжнародному фестивалі класичної музики LvivMozArt.
Це фестиваль, який вона заснувала у 2017 році.
А це Франц Ксавер Моцарт, син знаменитого Вольфґанґа Амадея Моцарта.
Він прожив у Львові понад 20 років, викладаючи і даючи тут концерти.
На цій центральній площі має з'явитися пам’ятник Францу Ксаверу Моцарту -
пошана від Оксани Линів європейській класичній традиції.
Я вважаю, що дуже-дуже важливо, щоб про нашу країну
розповідали не лише про Чорнобиль, чи політичні кризи,
чи Крим, чи війну на Сході, але й щось позитивне.
Оксана Линів готує українську національну страву - борщ. Для неї це
ідеальний спосіб розслабитися. І майже ритуал.
Борщ - це, власне, як трунок кохання. Кожна дівчина, яка закохана
і мріє завоювати свого коханого, мусить просто приготувати
йому дуже добрий борщ. Щоразу, коли на мене нападає туга
за домівкою, я готую борщ.
Вона заплатила високу ціну за свою міжнародну кар'єру.
Я помітила, що неможливо бути в цілому світі як удома.
І тоді я знайшла цю квартиру, і це чудове відчуття, коли -
що б не трапилося - я можу завжди повернутися сюди.
Вона розповідає про своє щасливе дитинство разом із братом.
Усі в родині Линів, включаючи батьків, пов’язані з музикою.
Тут видно наш сімейний оркестр. Його заснував мій батько.
Ми всі грали на різних музичних інструментах, також моя мама і її сестра,
також мої двоюрідні сестри і брат, а також мій рідний брат і я.
Батько пильно стежив за тим, щоб діти займалися також під час літніх канікул.
Наступна зустріч - у Львівському оперному театрі. Її кар'єра
почалася тут - як суфлерки і заступниці головного диригента.
Модельєрці цього театру вона й досі довіряє шити свій гардероб -
частинка батьківщини і для великого шоу в Байройті.
Жанна:  Я деталі заберу і зробимо півкруглий…
То є такий хороший крепдешин…
Оксана: Воно, по-перше, тягнеться, і мені…
Оксана Линів має великий вибір.
Зрештою у вбранні диригентки немає зразків для наслідування.
Якщо взяти варіант Оксани, то радше можна взяти силует з сюртука Моцарта,
а вже стосовно сучасних тканин воно має сучасний вигляд. Моє завдання -
зробити варіант зручний, в якому не буде ніяких моментів…
Ну, так, але який завжди буде виглядати ідеально зі сцени. Це дуже важливо.
Тому що я не можу в момент диригування за щось таке переживати.
Я маю бути трохи схожою на черницю, жартує Оксана Линів.
Чорне, просте, елегантне.
Її концертне вбрання не просто має відповідати її стилю,
але й не має заважати під час диригування.
І от настав цей величний момент: прем’єра у Байройті.
Родзинка нашого документального фільму.
Канцлерка Анґела Меркель теж прийшла.
Але жінку, через яку всі так схвильовані, поки не видно.
Вона ще в оркестровій ямі. Суворе правило Байройта.
Ніхто не може одразу збагнути, вона велика чи ні.
У що вона вдягнена? Сукня чи штани? На підборах чи без?
Як вона це робить - грайливо чи жорстко?
Музикальний твір захоплює чи не чіпляє? А стать не має значення.
Летючий голландець, що неспокійно блукає, бо проклятий жити вічно.
Лише коли моряк Сента помре, голландець зможе
звільнитися від свого прокляття і також померти.
Драматична історія.
Дебют Оксани Линів у Байройті: сильний і наелектризований.
Яка вражаюча прем'єра! Тріумф! Оплески тривали 12 хвилин.
Вона прийшла, прийшла. На самісінький верх.
За всю 145-річну історію фестивалю вона - перша жінка
за диригентським пультом у Фестивальному домі в Байройті!
Це справді найсильніші години в житті. Я не можу описати інакше.
Це те, коли все досягає кульмінації. Все, що ти наповнив своєю енергією.
Усі твої моменти, усі переживання, включаючи негативні переживання,
а також багато розчарувань, фіаско, які також трапляються.
Зрештою це, так би мовити, як битва - кожна секунда на рахунку.
А як ви відновлюєтесь? Чи одразу до нових звершень?
Зараз я збираюся спершу відсвяткувати.
А нам після такого тривалого часу з Оксаною настав час попрощатися.
Дякую за весь час разом і за цей вечір!